Let's start with Play.
On Google Fonts, I search for Play and we see it here.
This looks sort of similar, but not close enough for me.
All right, let's check out Rambla.
I search for Rambla and we see this here.
Once again, it's close but mm, not quite.
Next up, Lato.
Mm, Lato's looking really good.
I'm not 100%, so let's check the last one, and then we'll come back to this.
Finally we've got Arbitron.
I've searched for Arbitron and that is definitely not it.
So it looks like Lato's the winner.
let's add it to the website and see how it looks.
I'll click here.
I'll scroll down and copy this.
Inside the website I'll replace the sample here with the code for Lato and save
it, and now we just need to make sure we've got the right styles in our CSS.
So I'll copy this, come over to our CSS, and paste it in here.
So now, everything in the page should have Lato as the font.
We'll save it, come over to Chrome, and refresh the page.
Aha.
That's looking pretty good.
Let's compare it to the mock up.
Comparing our page to what we had in the mock up, we can see that
they're really, really similar but they're not quite exactly the same.
And that's because we have a few options that we need to play with.
I'm going to leave this as an exercise for you.
Come back into Google Fonts and start playing with how thick the lines are and
make sure that everything's in the right case, and
you should see this font look just like the design mock up.
So the correct answer here is Lato.